- We are back with Jessica Chastain
(audience cheering)
Jessica's new movie, The Good
Nurse, hits theaters tomorrow.
It's a thriller based
on actual events that I didn't
know that was a real thing.
And it is actual events
that will have you on
the edge of your seat.
Especially that it was real.
Meanwhile, it's almost Halloween
so we thought now would be a great time
for a round of What's Creepin' Up On Me?
- What's Creepin' Up On Me?
(audience clapping)
- Are you good at games?
Do you feel confident?
- Um, Yes.
- Okay. That did not feel confident.
- Did that sound confident?
(laughing)
- Did not sound confident.
Okay. Well here's how this game works.
Jessica will start with
her back to the screen.
I will give her clues about
what's creeping up behind her
without saying the name of the thing.
Then we're gonna switch sides and
Jessica will give me clues.
We can pass. If one is
too hard, just say pass.
And if we can correctly,
guess 10 things total
in two rounds, the
audience will win a prize.
- Oh geez.
(audience cheering)
- If we can't, well, sorry in advance.
(laughing)
And the clues are all
based around Halloween.
- Okay.
- Or hospital horrors for Jessica's movie.
I'm so scared right now about the game.
Okay. Okay, let's get in position.
- All right
- Okay. I'm getting in position.
- Okay. Okay.
- Let's go.
- Okay.
- Okay oh, a gurn.
- A gurney!
- Oh, sorry.
(bell dings)
Oh god uh.
- You cheated!
- Shoot!
- But that's okay
- Oh! Oh! This person has no
- Neck, no head.
- So, and
- They're decapitated
- And they're, And they're on an animal.
- That's dark.
What?
- They're on an animal.
- They're riding on
- The headless horseman
- Yes!
(bell dings)
- I'm not doing great.
(audience cheering)
- Oh! Co-Star!
- Eddie Redmayne
- Yes
(audience cheering)
(bell dings)
- Ouu Oh, the uh,
(wolf howling)
- A werewolf
- Yes!
(audience cheering)
- Okay, oh, these come get
you in case of an emergency.
- Paramedic?
- Ambulance
(audience cheering)
(bell dings)
- Oh, the, Okay, so
it's not a nurse, it's a
- Doctor.
- And they sometimes have
something for surgery
- For, Oh, scalpel?
- Yep.
(audience cheering)
(bell dings)
- Oh, these are big but not poisonous.
But they're furry and
they have eight legs.
- Spider.
- Yes, but a specific
(bell dings)
- Tarantula
(audience cheering)
- What am I saying?
Oh, these are, they come
they show up at your door on Halloween.
- Trick or Treaters.
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
(bell dings)
- And then
- Oh wait.
(loud horn sounds)
- We did a lot!
(audience cheering)
- How many did we get?
- Wait, how many did we get?
How many did we get?
We got eight.
- We only need two more!
- (audience cheering)
- Ok. Ok.
I'm Sorry
Where's okay?
- Okay, I've never done this before.
I've never done this, okay.
- I Kinda really messed up like a lot.
- No you did not, we got eight.
- But whatever, yeah.
- Okay.
- You were amazing.
Okay. Okay, I'm feeling
it, I'm feeling it.
- Alright, Oh my gosh, this is so hard!
Okay, so it is the undead.
- It's a zombie.
- Yes.
- And they are in
- Walking Dead
- place with a lot of trees.
- They're in a forest
- Of
(bell dings)
- zombies.
- Forest of zombies.
- Okay.
Now, before a show like
this, you have to take
- A pee
(audience laughing)
- You gotta make sure
you don't have the Corona
- Virus.
- So you do a
- So you do a swab, you test.
You do a test.
- What kind of test?
- Swab test. Covid Test.
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
(bell dings)
- Oh wait that's it! Oh we won!
(horn sounds)
- We did it. We dit it
(audience cheering)
- You were friggen amazing!
Alright, so we did it, we did it guys.
- Ya
Cause we're amazing.